i'm so excited to learn a recipe out of
what is the hottest cookbook out there
right now
okay well let's do it so we're gonna
make the
miso apple tart a take on the classic
french tart
but it takes like a little bit of a
twist in incorporating miso
into the glaze and into the franja pan
underneath it so
we're gonna start by making like a
cheaters fran japan
so you should have a bowl of butter and
brown sugar that's already paddled
together
and you're gonna add three tablespoons
of almond butter
right into the bowl and one tablespoon
of
white miso and then use your spatula
to kind of like paddle them together and
work them together into a paste
so once it's all paddled together
and it feels kind of smooth you have an
egg
hopefully nearby that you can crack
right into it
and that um and this time this is going
to kind of puff up
underneath the apples as it bakes on the
bottom layer with the egg in there
okay so i'll show you what mine looks
like mine is like a nice kind of
drizzly pasty situation so once you
once your egg is incorporated that's
kind of what it should look like
we get in there we work in it okay
so the next thing we're going to do is
slice some apples so you can set the
fringe pan aside gorge this is made
flirting
with my apples beautiful you're gonna
take your apple and you're gonna cut it
into four lobes like
basically cutting out the core so that's
what's left behind is just a little
square
piece of pore it makes perfect sense and
i slice apples for my daughters
like almost every night and i feel like
i'm always kind of reinventing the
wheels when i slice it
and i love this because i'm always
having to deal with the core
and this avoids that so i totally get it
there you go
and then you can kind of slice um
through them crosswise into little
like thin slices because then we can fan
them out really in a very
organized manner if that makes sense all
right so
this is my board and this is molly's
board and that's all
you need to know
let's move on from that okay let's throw
them on the chart
so we're just fanning them out adding
them right to the chart
and then um this needs to get glazed
so this is a mixture of brown sugar
butter heavy cream more miso and vanilla
and we're going to just lightly glaze
all of the apples with it
and that's going to help them cook down
and also just like give them a nice
sheen so that they don't dry out in the
oven so if you have a pastry brush
you're just kind of
going gently over them i've never
smelled anything like this
this is like walking into a caramel
apple toffee it totally like i love that
you added miso into this
and you know what else is that as soon
as we're done with this
we're gonna add salt to those because we
love savory desserts and in the meantime
we can bring in
our finished tarts ta-da
beautiful and then we're sprinkling
it with some mauldin because that
butterscotch in that friendly pan is
sweet and we want to bring out some of
the more savory notes of the almond
butter and the miso
and then we can just scoop ourselves a
little bit of ice cream here
and we'll try it together i think what
you're
bringing to the culinary world
has humor and whimsy and also
we need inventive combinations that like
you know we hadn't thought of whether
it's slicing a steako
pov or adding miso to the apple tart
you're bringing
so much innovation and imagination into
your work right
i'm going this is so incredible
i mean it tastes exactly how you hope
it tastes the surprise and delight
in in it is that it's that good
i can't thank you enough for doing this
show i've been so looking forward to
just honoring
what you're putting out there in the
world and um and now getting to eat your
food it's just such a gift
thank you molly baz so much
be sure if you haven't already to pick
up a copy of
cook this book a truly unique and
beautiful cookbook that does stand out
and molly your criteria to create
something unique and beautiful
well it really came true so go to the
drewberrymore show.com to get this
recipe recipe
i can't talk today you know what i'm
just here's what i need to do with this
mouth
just keep eating it's such a pleasure
thank you so much drew
oh molly's boss i love you so much